like I said I'm here for you tonight if
you want to keep going I will keep going
tonight what's up if you want to keep
going
that's Drake being booed off stage at a
Los Angeles festival it's been love I
love y'all I go by the name of Dre thank
you for having the awkward moment went
down after the rapper showed up as the
surprise headliner at Tyler the
creator's camp vlog na festival at
Dodger Stadium if you want to keep going
I will keep going tonight with something
an eyewitness who is at the show tells
ET the incident likely had to do with
anticipation that Frank Ocean would
appear the eyewitness says quote it was
never clear that Drake was the final
artist adding he came out acting like he
was only supposed to play a few songs
the eyewitness adds the only time he got
booed was when he kept asking if we
wanted to hear more songs and everyone
said no because we all thought Frank
Ocean was coming out after him Drake
responded taking to Instagram to have a
little fun with the situation writing
plot twist just signed a 10-year
residency at Camp Plagne sorry kids see
you every single year till you are 30
meantime Tyler the Creator
claps back at fans in a Twitter rant the
rapper said quote I thought bringing one
of the biggest artists on the planet to
a music festival was fire but flipside a
little tone death knowing the specific
crowd it drew some created a narrative
in their head and acted out like when it
didn't come true the rapper also changed
his Twitter bio to embarrassed by fans
right now but later went on to call the
incident low-key funny Drake has been in
the headlines recently after rumors
began swirling that he was dating Kylie
Jenner
that's not Union twisted but Kylie was
not in attendance at Drake's LA
performance instead she attended a
different show her ex Travis Scott's
Astroworld festival in Texas a source
recently told ET that Drake and Kylie
are not romantically involved and that
she'd still like to make things work
with Travis
[Music]